Next question comes from Thomas,
and his question has to do with mistakes.
Basically, you never seem to make any--at least in the videos.
Maybe you can talk a little bit about your design process in coming up
with these lectures and how mistakes figure in there.
There is always a trade off of how many mistakes we want to leave in,
and believe me, I make lots of them.
And I make them at various points in time.
So as I'm first thinking up the questions we're going to do, I'm coding up answers.
And I make mistakes there in a couple of ways.
One is, I just make errors.
I write something. It computes the wrong answer.
It generates an error.
I swapped the order of two arguments, or I pass the wrong thing in.
I'm making those mistakes all the time.
Those aren't very interesting ones, so I don't show them.
And then, when I'm recording the videos, I make mistakes there too.
And, sometimes errors have crept into the program
that I didn't notice when I was developing them.
I didn't write enough test cases, and then I have to decide what to do.
And mostly, those have ended up on the cutting room floor.
So, just as when you watch a movie or a TV show, you don't see most of the outtakes.
Sometimes after the credits, they roll a few of the outtakes
So believe me the errors are there, we're not just showing most of them.